now here's something that may or may not
appear in this week's newsletter
i may not be able to stomach talking
about it anymore beyond this segment
but a video went viral this week
featuring a clip from a show called
nine months with courtney cox now as the
title suggests the show is
supposed to document the journey of
various parents through pregnancy birth
and into the early days and months
of raising a newborn one of the couples
profiled in the show
are a man and a woman named ahanu
and patrona ohano is the mom
and patrona is the dead this is kind of
hard to keep track of because you know
since this is facebook we're talking
about and this is also modern society
we're talking about
there's a catch ahanu the mom identifies
as the dad and patrona the dad
identifies as the mom an article on the
federalist gives more background it says
quote
ahanu a female identifying as a male and
her partner patrona
a male identifying as a female were
caught off guard by the pregnancy news
because they both were using hormone
replacement therapy
as the episodes go on cox claims the
couple faces discrimination at the
doctor's office because someone wrongly
assumed each partner sex
they didn't even speak to me ahanu said
quote i just felt like they just made
assumptions making an assumption from
the very beginning without even asking
our names not asking a thing about us
patrona added
well just to make a side note here
that's because
when it comes to your biological sex now
really we don't need to say biological
sex because there's no other kind
um but when it comes to your to your sex
uh your name doesn't matter
we don't need anything we need to know
anything about your personality we don't
need to know what your hobbies are what
your interests what your hopes and
dreams are
because it's it's all that matters is
the biology
they determine that physically
which is why you could dig up the
remains of someone
long ago dead and tell what sex they
were
you can't interview them you can't ask
their name you can't ask how they
identify
and yet you can tell the sex often times
back to the federalists it says leading
up to the home birth the couple opted to
prevent
further which they opted to prevent
further medical discrimination and
trauma the show also documented the
couple's struggle to claim
my truth quote unquote and choose who in
their families will respect their wishes
to raise a non-binary child
100 said quote the gender binary was
very violent
and growing up i had a gender assigned
to me and it caused me a lot of
unnecessary trauma
it's very lonely and isolating like i
know my parents could do more
patrona also expressed reluctance that
his family would choose to ignore the
baby sex because their minds are filled
with christian supremacy
now this is all deranged enough as it is
but it gets worse
here is the actual viral clip mentioned
earlier it shows patrona the biological
father attempting to breastfeed the
newborn
you probably didn't think you'd get a
chance to see male breastfeeding on the
show today
and you certainly don't want to see it
i'm sure but here it is anyway let's
watch
i just felt really thankful for rahanu
for creating our family oh i put it over
here
the baby has been able to latch but
i've not been able to produce any milk
it's okay because
we're going to supplement the feeding
with formula so that
my baby is still getting the the
nutrients that they need
but i'm still feeling hopeful i
appreciate you so much for all your work
and i appreciate you also dating i'm
gonna die without
[Music]
is he getting any milk the person behind
the camera asks well no
he isn't because he's being breastfed by
his dad
and dads don't produce milk now it'll be
pointed out by some people attempting to
justify this grotesque display
that actually technically in some cases
men can lactate and that's true
there's always people ready with the
with the with the rare medical
exceptions saying well here's this crazy
exception i've i found on google which
which totally undermines the entire uh
sexual binary there have been a few
recorded instances of this
due to medical anomalies of or other
circumstances i think i think a certain
kind of tumor can have this effect
for example but these are
medical anomalies rare cases extreme
exceptions and there's no reliable
recorded instance of a man actually
producing enough milk to keep a baby fed
there are however billions of recorded
instances of women producing enough milk
for a baby because that
is how nature has designed it but as
we've seen
nature is often told to take a back seat
it is often subverted in order to serve
the emotional needs
of deluded narcissists speaking of
narcissism this is an aspect of our
contemporary
gender madness and really our
contemporary madness
as a whole it's an aspect that isn't uh
talked about a lot
there's a lot of mental illness at work
here clearly
but there's also something simpler and
more common which is narcissism
the conviction that myself
is the center of all things and all of
reality
must conform to my expectations for it
there's perhaps no picture that captures
narcissism
more profoundly or grossly
than that of a father calling himself a
mother while trying to breastfeed his
helpless infant
and what about that infant we're told
that the lifestyle choices other people
make are not
our business because nobody's being
harmed this isn't hurting anyone but out
they say but you know the baby counts
as someone the baby is a person
and he didn't choose to be caught in the
middle of this he didn't choose to
become a prop in this
macabre stage play
he didn't choose to be part of the
costume that is being worn here
and that's the case for many kids born
into these sorts of situations
or all of the kids born in these
situations none of them chose it
and really it's the case for all kids
actually
across across all of western culture
even those with moms and dads who are
actually moms and dads and call
themselves as such
we have a whole generation of people
born into a reality that has been
completely redefined
to suit what was once a tiny minority
all humans in history until now were
born into a world where at least the
most
basic realities were acknowledged and
recognized
we now have at least one generation in
the west
and more to follow who will be deprived
of that blessing and it's a sad thing
that we can call it a blessing
that we could call reality to simply
live in reality
to be raised in reality
and to be taught about the most basic
aspects of reality the fact that we have
to even call that a blessing now
tells you everything you need to know
but we have
general we're gonna have generations of
kids millions of kids
who are born without that not given that
so is is this affecting someone
is this harming other people yeah i'd
say so
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated